die lage in minsk wird für die
demonstranten definitiv bedrohlicher
gestern gab es massenfestnahmen nicht
nur die journalisten die 20 die dort
einkassiert wurden von der polizei die
meisten konnten rund zwei stunden wieder
gehen sondern eben auch fast 100
menschen die jetzt immer noch in
gefängnissen oder bei polizeibehörden
sitzen und befragt werden einfach nur
deshalb weil sie für ihre freiheit auf
die straße gegangen sind und wenn man
das sieht zwar jetzt nicht der erste tag
muss diese festnahmen gegeben hat dann
sieht man dass lukaschenko durchgreifen
will möglicherweise noch nicht im ganz
großen stil aber 100 festnahmen sind
eine ganz große menge und er will
einschüchtern
er will verhindern dass diese
demonstration weitergehen
es sieht nicht danach aus dass er das
zum zeitpunkt jetzt zumindest schafft
man könnte annehmen dass die menschen
große angst bekommen
durch diese festnahme aber nein weil die
frauen sind dann gestern abend wieder
durch die straßen gezogen und haben
gesagt jeden tag haben sie gerufen dass
sie jeden tag weiter marschieren wollen
denn immer wieder berichtet über
angriffe über folterungen von
demonstranten die festgenommen worden
sind nun also auch journalisten den
gewahrsam genommen werden wie gefährlich
ist die situation jetzt für deine
weißrusse weißrussischen kollegen und
natürlich auch wie internationale presse
die vor ort ist ich glaube die lage ist
nicht zu vergleichen mit der durch die
demonstranten gehen denn die welt schaut
da momentan nicht mehr so genau hin wir
wissen zum beispiel nicht was mit den
100 passiert ist die dort festgenommen
wurden bei den journalisten weiß man ist
das waren insgesamt 20 die in diesem bus
mitgenommen wurden einige wurden dann
wieder freigelassen andere werden
weiterhin befragt und da geht
lukaschenko darum natürlich zu versuchen
ihr einfluss zu nehmen dass die
journalisten eben eingeschüchtert werden
und angst bekommen zu berichten angst
bekommen darüber zu berichten wenn dann
auf dem platz massenfestnahmen
vorgenommen werden von dem uns dran